he's like I'm at the lowest point of my
life right now I don't know
what I'm here for I don't know what I
want to do or I don't even know how to
move forward and all I said to him was
well get up off your ass and go run a
mile but he did it and he called me
afterward he's like great that was just
great mate it's just that one little
step forward was everything to say okay
somebody cared about me to call me
somebody told me to do go do something
and that's all we really need to nurture
people is to get them moving forward
just one step at a time if somebody told
me when I got out and I was having a bad
day I need you to go eat a meal right
now and then I need you to go you know
rest for a second and then I need you to
get up and I need you to go run and then
call me afterwards check I know that and
that's not just military there's anybody
like thank you for you missing guys I'm
gonna go do that right now and then
you're gonna feel a little bit better
command I just accomplished something
and that's something that we're losing
sight on as accomplishments you know we
don't have to be a first class the best
in the world or anything it's just gotta
be our best version of ourselves